[Music]
welcome to sodcast number three my name
is john striker meyer
today we are joined by our guest a
fellow sog recon man nick brockhausen
nick welcome to the show
thank you tucker
glad to be here
indeed so this would be one of our more
uh definitely uh informative as well as
entertaining uh interviews we've been
looking forward to it for a while
anyways i like to start off with the
reading from the first of nick's three
books and again these are books that are
not only are they well written but they
document our song missions
during your tour of duty
and what was the total time at ccn nick
for the second and third tours
uh i think it was like 17 months
you know on the ground on the ground yes
and so
for we had the secret war for eight
years we had uh by 1970 we had three
operational bases
one down south the ccs one at ccc
contoum
and then ccn north at danae
and you landed there in the fall
of 1970.
yeah and so um
the first book i'm going to go to steps
we refer to it as i was sentenced there
in the fall of seven indeed so the first
book that nick has written that came out
years ago has been reprinted thankfully
and it is we few again excellent tight
writing stories about the missions
and also there's a lot of um
reflections
about the unique relationship between
green berets
and the indigenous troops they work with
in this case your brew
on that team rt habu right i like that
it's got a rhyme
the brew from rt
okay
we can make a good rap song out of that
we could do that
the second book
we have whispers in the tall grass which
is also available both are available on
amazon
and another read that continues on with
more stories later into the tour of duty
and so today we will be focusing on
these forks the stories the man behind
them
the unique personality and fortunately
for our readers that like the first two
books
we have a third book that is in the
process of being produced vagabonds
tourists in the heart of
darkness darkness
and that's just the perfect uh
headline for another book
that will go into missions that you ran
and stories it's it's basically the
adventures i had with two or three of my
other
friends
from special forces for 40 years after
after we left the service but before
there were contractors
there were vagabonds
people that went out there and basically
built the industry indeed that uh you
know that later became you know
blackweiser and all the other companies
indeed indeed so um
in
we few
one of the uh uh one of many compelling
stories here
but there's one mission
where
your team is getting inserted into the
dmz
if i can interject something please and
stay close to the mic
most people don't understand i did not
write this these books
as a great american novel and they
aren't it's not an archival it's not
something that you know somebody's gonna
go look up and for research for their
phd
i wrote these books as a catharsis
i was uh going to a difficult time in my
life i went back to to basically spend
time with the guy i'd spent the two
years running recon with
and during that time i
wrote these two books and i wrote them
as a tribute
to the people that i knew in that outfit
and the people that had gone before me
and came after me for that select group
of men that was all they were written
for what wasn't really written for the
general public i'm pleased
that the general public finds them
entertaining or or
informative but the books are really
written for for my peers and i'm the
highest accolade i can get is from
somebody who actually ran recon and goes
wow you're a man you're spot on that's
that's better than getting the pulitzer
prize
i know the feeling and and as a peer
uh
nick arrived at ccn after i left a few
months later
all that bad [ __ ] happened after he left
indeed indeed
and as a peer uh fellow recon guy this
book is amazing each book is uh one i've
gone back to reread because they're not
only is it re
written well
but the stories are compelling and the
way you articulate the relationship with
the men you serve with
from the special forces side
but even more detailed information i've
seen anywhere
on the relationship between a green
beret and his indigenous troops oh yeah
it was just outstanding
and so i wanted to start off with uh one
of the chapters from we few
where
on this mission
rt habu is going into the dmz
and could you uh just lay out because on
a team
and this team was just the two americans
you and mac and explain who mack is and
the one zero one one and then how many
little people you had and when we say
little people we say that with the term
of endearment great endearment indeed or
talked about our indigenous people that
in your case you're brew
in
in fact i mean like that the brew team
leader
had been fighting the communists for
nine years
nine straight years they butchered his
family you know he and he hated the
communists
and and he was uh
while he was subordinate to our command
he was also a mentor
to us on teaching us you know survival
skills uh combat skills and how to
operate working with with the brew and
that he was actually
i think the closest thing you could call
it would be like a a war chief
in uh in one of the
plains tribes like the crow the dog
soldiers or something like that you know
he basically
was the most effective combat leader
amongst the brew and was treated as such
and we treated him like that but he uh
he a lot of times would give us advice
you know like
one time when he was always amused about
the fact that we always made captain
manus very angry and captain maintenance
was the ceo of a recon company of ccn at
that time and i remember one time he was
chewing he was chewing us out mac and i
he goes oh
number 10. all time make captain made
buku angry
and he pointed at his testicles and he
said this
is not the thinking organ
civil philosophy what was the profound
wisdom oh yeah you know and we a lot of
times we got that i mean we had well
not to get too far afield that's okay
the the monyards are very special people
they were essentially an iron age
tribal
unit and there were
oh god i used to have a great book and
somebody stole it from me and if you're
out there i'm going to eventually
remember who you are
and it was all the ethnic groups of
vietnam it's about that thick you know
you know army field manual
with the
vanilla cover you know and
and it outlined every tribe
what their marriage ceremonies were like
what the the taboos were uh how they
were marked what kind of clothing they
were i mean all that
but the the mountain yards were the
hilltop
mountain yard means mountain people
been in french
and they were
they were considered by the vietnamese
both the north and the south to be less
than than human
and they did their
dead level like a monyard in the south
vietnamese army couldn't be an officer
they could be ncos but they couldn't be
an officer
they could be an officer in the north
vietnamese army
but not nassau but both sides
tried to eradicate them as a people
both before before the war and after the
war you know the
they they were the people that north
vietnamese used yellow rain on
you know and nerve gas and tried to
eradicate the people of the highlands
so but they were very special to us they
were absolutely excellent fighters the
finest you could find
totally fearless and totally fair well
when you when you say fearless most of
us that are combat veterans know that
term is overused right you know it's
controlling your fears you know could
they control their fear better than most
people yes yes no more accurate i say i
like that yeah so on this mission you
still haven't explained who mac is okay
so
mclaughlin was the 1-0 the 1-0 is a
recon team leader
when
when
when snake adams went home
and
danzer took over habu as the 1-0
the very next mission they ran was the
recovery for doc watson and baby son
lloyd
to try and get their bodies back in that
and
after that was over horton
who had been wounded really bad there
was uh danzer horton
and mack
and i think jimmy johnson was still on
the team of that so he was like the one
three or one four
and when they went in to get doc watson
and baby son lloyd they they found the
bodies hanging in the trees where the
strings had separated right they looked
like they were asleep
they were only about 20 yards
out
yeah that was the mission where the chop
was extracting right had the had the sf
men hanging from the ropes sami
hernandez uh right his rope broke he
fell he's the only one that survived
only want to survive he was knocked on
conscious separated shoulder as the
helicopter further lifted out it was hit
with something it turned around and
crashed into the granite space or a
mountain killing everybody right and
this is where habu went in for a bright
light which is a mission to recover
down teams or in this case bodies right
so after they ran that mission mack took
over as the 1-0 or the recon team leader
and i became the one one now there were
there were two other guys that were in
the interim there there was a guy named
steve hank and steve i'm sorry i didn't
put you in the books you should have
been in there
and uh and a guy named ken holmes
that were also on hubbu at that time ken
eventually went up to become an ast
right of at the top and was one of the
best they had up there absolutely yeah
but uh habu essentially then became
cored out with
uh lemuel mcglothrin mini mac or the
combat pygmy
and cookie
robert cook and myself
and the three of us ran the longest
time together sure mac was the the team
leader mac's job was to have the radio
the radio stayed with him so we could
talk to covey
my job was to fight the team
as a unit
between cook and i we we basically
fought the team as a unit yeah and then
mack took care of the radio because i
have a tendency when i'm
hyperventilating to stutter on the radio
and cooks from
georgia and you know how they are nobody
can understand them
so on this particular mission
uh the first helicopter goes in matt
gets off
and as your helicopter you're on the
second helicopter as it's descending
um reading from the book now we view
we aren't even on short final
when i hear the pilot screaming abort
abort
i look down where mac landed and gets
sick to my stomach
he's lying on his back
and right next to him
is the trapped door
to a bunker concealed right
at the crest of the trail
he has fallen on it
and plugged the door
there are two nva trying to crawl out of
a side entrance and the yards shoot them
worse yet
i can see about 15 other likely bunkers
up slope
on the opposite side
i am standing on the skid and i feel the
ship start to gain power
i instinctually know that they are going
to abort and pull up
which will leave mack with too few men
to save himself
i slammed the barrel of my car 15
in the back of the pilot's
head
and his helmet and i scream into the mic
put this [ __ ] bird down where he is
now
he chops power other words he reduces
power
we slam into the slope
we all jump in
our throne clear i land heavily
when i hit the ground my ears feel like
i just ripped them off
i still feel
the headset when i jumped
the bird screams loudly as it winds up
and is gone
immediately i get the yards in some sort
of fighting perimeter
where we can at least hold on or fight
our way
to better ground i run up in a crotch
and max says
why did you land
i told them to abort
he did
there are bunkers all over the hill to
our right and eight of us can fight
a lot harder than five i yell back
he grabs the radio handset
go tie in the team and let me bring in
some air in this case bringing tactical
air
i work my way down slope where i see
zompot
team member
stand up and fire methodically
he slants he fires like he is on the
rifle range he is standing upright just
like we did at the range
it is almost amusing because he looks
like a poster child for the nra
i think he's shooting at nothing
he is new on the team and this is his
first mission
i yell at bob and tua to see what he's
firing at
a grenade goes off over by where tua is
and he yells at the team
because he thinks one of the team has
thrown it and it fell short
i've run over to where a zop pod is and
down the trail i see the crumpled bodies
of three nva
with a whole shitload of canteens on
bamboo poles lying amongst their bodies
they had just walked up the trail
he just stood up yelled something like
hey
and dropped all three
that's pretty good discipline or
he just got lucky
we are starting to take ground fire now
and the tempo is picking up
i run back up slope
well i trudge
up slope-like
i use the team to tie in closer and i am
working my way back up to where mac is
beside the bunker
nearby i can see a group of nva and
green khakis break from cover by some
rocks to his left front
they start to try to flank him cumin and
bong drop all of them
who make it to a small wash below
mac
cumin throws a grenade down into just as
a thick grenade comes lofting out of the
wash lands where mac is and explodes
i hear max scream god damn it
that's just unbelievable well how did
mac do with that well you know let me
start with dm10 indeed dm10 is
demilitarized zone number 10 target
and it's
the the terrain is an old caldera
like the inside of a crater
with the overgrown brush on the top and
a trail that ran down to the center of
it
we knew there was a division plus in
that area
and what i didn't know at the time but
mac knew and he didn't want to inform me
because he knows that i have delicate
feelings
was that they were inserting two other
teams to try and
the whole
the whole concept would basically stir
them up till they get up on the radio
and they start talking so they can rdf
them
call back to guam roll out the b-52s
they get a pedicure on the way over and
found the place in the snot
and and there were air packages that
were prepared for the other two teams
that were on the outside and adjacent to
our no bomb box of six by six
i didn't know this at the time which is
why when the cavalry showed up we had
everything we had a1es we had fast
movers we had the choppers you know
every
i think i even saw air nook mom go by
but there was a lot of air available to
us that day
and our our mission was to go in and
basically try and stir them up
get get them up out of the hole we knew
that they and we went in at pot time
every day
in in vietnam between such such an hour
and such september time it's like siesta
time in mexico so they
they were part time we landed right in
the middle of their nook mom lunch
and
all hell broke loose
because when they came in mack bailed
out on the right hand side
and he hit the the opening to the bunker
and it caved in underneath him so he's
laying on his back like a ninja turtle
scrambling around and i didn't know it
but he had told
the the left abort abort abort
because he realized there was no reason
to bring more people in there we're all
going to die well he's on the ground
with three people not five
himself and two other yards
and i had
myself in four yards on my chopper so
you know
there was no time to explain to the to
the pilot that who by the way i met
later years later and he goes oh yeah i
remember you you're the crazy son but
stuck a gun in the back of my head
wow
i shoved a gun there was no way to to
get the immediacy across to him i had to
threaten him
so i stuck the gun in the back of his
helmet atlanta chopper now
and the reason was
it was getting ready to turn very bad
and mack and the other two yards were
dead unless we got on the ground
so we got on the ground and
you know it just
uh
when i said it was park time everybody
was awake five minutes later and
shooting at us
you know i remember looking up it when
you look at the terrain there this it's
a huge just imagine a crater wall
that's been eroded
and and the center cone has been eroded
and where we were was in that center
cone
and that's where there was like within
20 meters
there were four bunkers
all of them manned by nba
and on the slopes
where everybody woke up there must
easily
another 100 150 just on that one side
that suddenly woke up and started
shooting at us then they they couldn't
get at us because we got into a gully
and we finally rolled down into that
because we were taking fire from
everywhere
we rolled down into this gully
and they started organizing so they
could mass on us because they know if
they don't mass on us the air force is
going to come and blow everything into
smithereens so the whole idea is get on
top of you grab you by the belt buckle
and and stay with them
so about that time you know we were
they they came up they started throwing
grenades uphill at us
and one of the grenades went off right
next to where mac was well i'm trying to
tie in the team and get a
i can't do anything on the ground
the guy who's killed more people in this
world is the guy who invented hit the
dirt
because you can't see anything from the
dirt you've got to get up and move if
you can't get up
shoot move and communicate your debt
so i'm up doing what i'm supposed to do
which is fight the team
and i go back up and i'm going oh my god
it landed right where mac was
so i i went up to check on him
and he's got the
handset cupped in his hand like this
he's leaning against his rucksack and
he's got his pants down
and he's handling his junk
and i'm thinking to myself you know this
is the coolest son of a [ __ ] in the
world we're in the middle of firefight
and he's masturbating
[Laughter]
well what had happened the grenade had
gone up and it nicked him on the inside
of his thigh right next to his junk and
that and he was just checking to make
sure the equipment was there didn't want
any brain damage yeah no brain damage
yeah right yeah so he's he looks at me
like you know
what are you looking at and covey keeps
calling you know
calling us saying where do you want to
you know where do you want us to lay it
in and that and i took the handset away
from him i said you'll have to give him
a minute because uh my 1-0 is busy
fondling himself and i think he may be
masturbating
so and dick cheney was that was the uh
was the the covey and he's going well
we'll take that into account
put him back on the line
so it was a bad target a lot of a lot of
bad people oh yeah
let me just go because this this is the
next couple of progress you're still
there
we both look up slope to our east and
the platoon we had driven to ground
has been joined by about 10 more
stallard lads
and is getting ready to assault us
the yards are dropping them like they
were ducks in a shooting gallery
but the small arms fire
isn't slacking off at all
we are getting heavy fire from both
sides now
and i can count at least six bunker
openings and with muzzle flashes
some of them are only 40 yards away
mother mcrae this is bad bad bad
we are tucked into a wars so he can't
really get at us but if they can lay
enough fire on us
they will be able to keep our heads down
then they will hit us with the b-40s and
brushes
that will be the end of rt hibou
the end of my dreams of becoming
president and any dreams i have of ever
becoming a porno star
mack yells at me
the guns are on the way the slicks are
about 10 minutes out hang on
oh no red ryder
i think i will just give up
maybe they won't put me in a tiger cage
with someone who was more interested in
his future as a breeding stud
crump the high explosives go off
west about 50 meters oh great
someone brought a mortar to the party
how novel
now we are all really [ __ ]
they can reach us into ours with that
i'm trying to figure out some great
tactical wizardry
that will allow me to get out of this
alive
but all i can come up with is becoming
invisible
i look over at the torrent bodies of the
two nva we shot coming in
i am wondering
if i can fit into one of the uniforms i
did and slip away into the crowd
i'm wondering
i remember reading how some planesmen
had escaped from a war party of sue by
crawling inside a dead horse carcass and
concealing himself i look around
nope
there aren't any horse carcasses here
but there are plenty of pissed off
indians and they are starting to get
organized
i hear the unmistakable
of a minigun and the slope in front of
me erupts causing bunches of the green
khaki tribe go down
rockets a 40 mike mike start hitting the
slope to the rear
i have my irkten emergency radio and i
can hear covey talking to another ship
that has been hit and gone down
the crew was out and slicks from the
package are dropping in to pick them up
the cobras bank up and to the right and
a pair of spads come in
guns chewing up the real estate
get down
nape mack yells i didn't see the
canister drop
but then a ruling fire storm erupts in
front of us and envelops any of the
survivors of the assault force
who were splashing
into the bunkers
there is a blast of heat behind me and i
can hear someone screaming
it is too far away to be one of us
fry you little ricey net
napalm sucks oxygen out of the area
making it hard to breathe
i don't notice because when i'm scared
shitless i have a tendency to
hyperventilate
so oxygen isn't yet a problem
the mortar has stopped
maybe we got lucky
very lucky incredible writing too well
what but most people don't understand i
mean it sounds like some action movie
but people don't understand the
concentrations that the north vietnamese
had in the demilitarized zone at that
time they were moving division south
and they had base camps they had bunker
systems they had refit facilities i mean
all and our job was to find them
we had to you know our specific mission
we were trying to find a pipeline that
they were supplying their tanks
because they were seeing
we were seeing t-54 tanks south of the
demilitarized zone
and
early 71 then yeah wow yeah there was uh
you know the the the soviet tank
normally carries a 55 gallon drum on the
back actually they're 44 gallon drums
that are on the back two of them
for spare fuel supply and they also used
the diesel fuel they injected on top of
the heads and create a smoke screen
using the exhaust and that but none of
the tanks were showing up with those
extra fuel tanks on the back so they had
to be getting fuel from somewhere if
they weren't bringing it down by the
trucks then we had to figure out how
they were getting the fuel and that's
when we eventually stumbled onto the
pipeline that they had run from actually
there were three of three pipelines
three already all in the dmz uh they
came came one skirted over through laos
and came down into the amazing one yeah
one came down to the dmz and i think one
of them really went way around and down
south and actually entered almost just
above where ccc's northern boundary was
for their okay
but the the reason we were there was
basically that you're doing in recon
find out what the other guy is up to
we knew there was high concentrations in
there
but when you read that particular
chapter it sounds like you know we
there's thousands of people again and
says well
the north vietnamese are like the
germans in world war ii
you beat the snot out of them and then
sit down to reload they're gonna come
back with a counter counter-attack and
that's just what they did
as soon as we hit them and we landed in
the middle of their nook mom party
they got they got organized immediately
and started putting maneuver troops on
us from out of those bunker systems
and
what i found out later was all the air
that had been laid on by papi boudreau
and and the other people the launch site
was actually in preparation because they
figured we were going to get our titner
ringer and we were going to need all the
air support that we had
which is the key note of this chapter is
basically
the use of combined arms which is
something that we developed in vietnam
and still used today
air power and overwhelming technology
makes up it's a force multiplier you can
use a small group of people to do more
than a division can do
you know and eventually the projects we
we made the north vietnamese redirect 50
000 troops
just to take care of us that's 50 000
troops that weren't fighting our troops
on the battlefield and weren't invading
this out they were there specifically to
protect their logistical lines from
a mall and the night visitors which
would be us
indeed
but
very
it was a tough
that was a tough target and i ran
dm-10
four times
four times four times and almost a fuel
line no no and anytime it was a major
headquarter i mean that that whole wall
nor north and eastern wall
was nothing but bunkers and tunnel
systems and everything i mean i don't
think anybody really got in there and
did a survey of it
unless you know the cubans snuck in
there looking for porno magazines he
might have gone through the times
but it was a real
uh developed complex they had storage
caves they had uh bunker systems for
and they had a major uh coaxial cable
that was uh connecting everything and
had any aircraft everywhere
37 millimeter 57 millimeter laid down
all the 12.5 all protecting that area
it's a key area obviously we wanted to
know what was going on in it so we we
went in dm10 dm9 and i think dm6 was
just above that
those three
targets i ran dm 10 four times and my
cumulative time on the ground
was less than three hours
oh my god and everyone was like this a
lot every one of them
i mean this was the worst one was the
one with mac but yeah i mean
i remember one time he got him our total
time on the ground was like 16 minutes
and by the time 16 minutes were up i had
expended half the ammunition i had taken
in with me
did you ever find any the fuel line
i i think
i think it was jesse campbell
and keith larson
and uh mcdowell
mcdowell was jesse the one zero with
idaho yeah
yeah i think i think they were the ones
that that found the pipeline the first
time i had to give jesse a call yeah
yeah
the thing with jesse is don't talk to
him on the radio because it takes them a
while
to explain what's going on
but he gets the job done eventually
yeah well
in the second book there's a chapter
about uh called the night before
christmas and we will get to that
shortly
about him and larson and mcdonald
but like another aspect of we few your
first book
uh i want to get back to the story
because one of the things you capture
here
is the action and the sense of of what
it's like to be on the ground
and then you throw in a couple of your
little twists your little editorials of
what you're thinking while on the ground
while under fire
and finally like you said for those four
times during that target you're only
there for three hours and in this case
your first time in
mac the one zero tells you hey the birds
are on the way
so you're checking things out and you're
going to be out in the first slick
so i'll take it from here in the book
the first slick comes in
slams down about 10 yards from me
i run toward it and start throwing
little people on board
i'm about to dive in when it is suddenly
up and gone
i stand there
momentarily with feelings of despair
betrayal and a big oh [ __ ]
however i haven't got time for hurt
feelings
i have to get back to where mac is or
they will leave me here
and all these pissed off people will
blame me for ruining their lunch hour
i run over to mack and the second bird
slams into the ground almost on top of
us
we dive inside
cumin lands on top of me
and we start to lift
the door gunners on both sides are
burning their guns out on full auto and
they have plenty to shoot at
the nva are trying to get
right on top of us because the guns and
the spads are killing everything except
what is about 20 yards from the chopper
we are on
you can feel the rounds hitting the
chopper
a staccato metal thunk thunk thunk
from where i am lying on the floor i can
see an nva officer running at us with a
pistol
and yelling at his men
[ __ ]
this boy must have watched too many war
movies
i wonder how he can run that far that
fast having
such big balls i just don't know how he
did it
i can't get my gun up because i'm half
lying on it
so i just pull the trigger
and let it rip
we are lifting and i can't see if i got
him
a grenade flies in
matt kicks it and it rumbles out the
side of the bird another grenade bounces
off the gunner's helmet and falls out
the gunner swats at his face with one
hand
like he's shooing away some nasty bug
but keeps burning up the gun with one
long continuous burst
the engines are screaming up to full
power and i can see rounds chewing up
the overhead and inside the bird
then we are up and away
there is another sudden rush of hot air
from ordnance going off real close and
the chopper jumps up from the concussion
but we are still gaining altitude
pulling free
and getting some sky getting up and
beyond the 12.5
millimeters and all those other weapons
trying to pull us back down
yeah just another dance sock
well i mean you know
it sounds like it's unique but it's not
yeah i mean i mean you ran missions the
same way
you know you
you know the the idea that you have an
overview of everything that's going on
in combat that's [ __ ]
you see what's in your immediate
vicinity and then talking to others you
eventually put together the whole
picture in that
but most of what i remember that target
is confusion
fear
anger
and uh
and it was a lot it was a lot i saw
like i said when i said weird they were
rushing us
when that nba officer came up he had
about eight guys with him
that that were still standing the the
door gunners had chopped up the
formation that he was leading in that
but uh he had about eight guys still
with him and then to this day i admire
his his courage oh yeah he stood there
like with that maricopa pistol and was
firing at us and i think he's the one
that threw the grenade that mack kicked
out
yeah i mean that the guy was hard
charger man he was uh and i did my gun
was laying underneath me so i just
reached down with my thumb it was like
sticking out in front of my face like
that it was pointing at him so i just
pulled the trigger
bad move because i couldn't hear [ __ ]
afterwards right now the gun in that and
i think cooman may have nailed him
you know he was right next to me and i
heard him firing but uh the guy to this
day hey here's to you nugent i hope you
made it indeed you certainly deserved it
well at that point in the early time at
ccn you were still carrying a car for a
car 15 before you transfer it over to an
rpd later in your time right
to do what you're carrying a car 15
later
months later i never transferred to the
rpd we had an rpd and on a team on the
team okay i wasn't sure that's why let's
saw it off our rpd what's that little
conniving cuban stripped all the parts
out there and then we got to get the
conniving cube in a little ink here
that's bob castillo
from uh at that time rt idaho also yeah
a real troublemaker well you know what a
hell of a real team had a certain
ambiance in the criminal side they did
yeah
everybody had different weapons and that
and i love to ask for you go up there
and go i want a swedish cave with a
silencer i'd give you one i want six
thompsons and a case of 45 ammunition
because i'm feeling a little belligerent
today i want to go to the rain you got
it yeah
but we had the rpd and the rpd was great
sawed off it slowed down the cyclic rate
of fire a bit because when you you cut
it off just ahead of the gas port
and uh
but it produces a gout of blue-green
plasma out the end of it that scares the
[ __ ] out of everybody especially at
night
but the problem with the rpd was links
because the our rpd uses a
a canadian continuous belt it's hooked
see the m60 and the 242 they used a
disintegrating link in other words that
when the round is fed into the chamber
right and it ejects that link is thrown
out
and you can put a belt together by
putting those little links together but
with the
the rpd was like the german they had the
half moon
um link right and then you just slid the
shelves in and they were hard to get
so everybody carried something to put
your used belts in as you used them up i
kept a claymore bag
that would broken out on on the side so
i could shove the used links in there
and i carried the rpd on specific
targets okay we were doing a bright
light right i carried the rpd we needed
the firepower no food no water no food
no water you're gonna you're not gonna
need that you're not gonna be here long
enough for that just one survival ration
usually a pir that you kept in the inner
thigh pocket to keep it hot
right yeah and water but none of the
extra rations you're going in
you want every grenade and every round
of ammunition you can get
so i carried when i carried the rpd i
also carry the car 15 at the same time
is that right i carried the rpd and i
had one two three
three fully round loaded drums
on me hanging on me
and one in the gun and one in the gun
and then i carried a car 15 slung in the
back
and uh ak vests with six magazines on it
30 round magazines because eventually
gonna run out of ammo enough because
everybody on the team carried an extra
belt for that machine gun
right so i had on the ground somewhere
around 1500 rounds
belted up if i needed them oh yeah but
and i had another you know what uh six
six times 30 180 rounds for the car car
15.
i i switched from the car because uh
somebody stole my sawed-off shotgun
i i taught myself how to load the rpd
with one hand reloaded
and i needed something other than a
pistol to protect myself when i was
doing that so i had gotten a an old
coach gun 12 gauge double barrel right
and the filipinos up there sawed it off
and made up like extension for your
wrist and that's it took the shock up
and i kept that in a slide holster
behind my back and i carried
25 rounds of shotgun for it
uh somebody most of them double up buck
and slug right yeah
because if you needed if while you're
changing magazines you have somebody
runs up on you gotta have something to
defend yourself i actually ended up
taking the the 12 gauge shells apart
and instead of putting double up buck in
there i started putting um either
nickels or this or the 10 10 dong piece
right the brass ten dong piece actually
held together really well when you fired
it and if
in inside eight feet it would cut a man
in half
i know that for a fact yeah yeah it will
kill a man and cut him in half
one barrel
wow
so different weapons for different
missions yeah
well i want to go to your second book
for a couple more chapters here
and
the second book of course we're talking
about whispers in the tall grass
chapter five twas the night before
christmas oh yeah
so set us up a little bit about uh what
the night before chris what the mission
was right and then how jesse campbell's
uh enters into your
into your experience there
first of all i want everybody to know
that i no longer correspond with any of
the people in that team
i don't hang out with them they don't
come to my my family affairs and most of
them are still down south
all right rt idaho good team
uh jesse campbell was the uh 1-0 at the
time 1-0 i think mcdowell
was a 1-1
now george mcdowell
if you can imagine somebody who has all
the temperament of a gut shot wolverine
and a stick of dynamite
pretty good description of him if he's
not breaking something he's destroying
something
punching somebody out really good recon
guy yeah keith larson
who's uh from my home state of minnesota
um
a really really nice guy another good
recon man and i think um
mariano or raimonde one of the two was
on there and anyway they're
they get the mission to go out there and
uh it's ecstatic they're gonna sit on
top of the hill
and become a carbuncle in uh north
vietnamese supply chain
get there they gotta eventually mass on
them run them off so they're on top of
this hill
they they get set up to go in they naped
it they prepped it with the guns they
realized when they got on the top that
there was there had been a major unit
there it hadn't been a couple of trail
watchers because they found 20 or 30
bodies on the top of the hill
and they were all dressed in the same
uniform had the same markings and that
so they they knew that they had they'd
hit the gold mine so to speak
now where they were at you could see a
major trail
connection for the ho chi minh trail
going uh i think it's highway
91 east of the ashow
in that area there and
they were moving troops down right so
they get up there they get set up and
they they end up calling what we call a
world series
a world series is a emergency radio call
to to let everybody in the command know
i have more
than a regiment
in the open
as a target
bring me help
so they they called the world series
there was the entire north vietnamese
regiment moving down this trail system
and on top of that was a special group
that were all dressed in gray fatigues
and that were obviously caucasians
no kidding the either east germans or
cubans or russians or what because uh
the north vietnamese there's a lot of
north uh uh east germans and russians
and cubans as their advisors for their
anti-aircraft and chinese and chinese
well chinese are in everything yeah they
uh but they there was one special group
that was moving down
in the open where they could see them
that had great fatigues on
and don audi murphy
was flying covey
to understand murphy
one needs to dig deep into the dark side
murphy's up there flying around his
motorized sports car and that you know
and he's directing air strikes for him
and about the time they get going and
they're starting to really lay in air
strikes on this regiment in the open
out of the woods trundles of t-54 tank
which was
part of the reason we were looking for
pipelines was that tank had no spare
tanks on it right it had no 55 gallon
drums on the back of it it was and it
was obviously far enough down they were
getting fuel for somewhere
and they destroyed that tank with with
air strikes and then of course
danang
interrupts in the middle of everything
to tell them that they want the team to
go down there and get some pieces off
that tank
pieces pieces you know get the gun sites
you know get us something to bring back
that we can brag to the girls in the
club i guess you know
and of course
you know mcdowell's trying to suppress
jesse's uh you know
tell jesse to do something it gets done
you know so he didn't want to go down
the valley and the yards are all going
we go to the tank we know come back we
we
we died down there
so they scratched going down to the tank
and getting souvenirs for it and they
they worked that
perfectly one one of the problems had
when they went in
there was a 12.7 machine gun below the
slope from them
that was chewing up the aircraft coming
in to resupply them so they decided to
get rid of it with hand grenades so
keith is crawling down closer to the
edge trying to throw hand grenades over
the edge and knock out this heavy
machine gun
and it
hits a tree and bounces back in front of
mcdowell's position
then crawls over to him to explain to
him the idea of grenades is to kill the
enemy not the team
this is called combat counseling
but yeah
really good mission uh
they came back for now they were still
all juiced up when they got back to da
nang and that we were sitting in a club
well actually they started in the club
and then somebody told them i'd made a
beer run and i had three cases of bomby
bomb my hooch
so they ended up in my hooch for the and
after after the war celebration yes
indeed and i got the whole story and i i
put it in that chapter excellent
excellent mission by by rt idaho yeah
and keith larson
jesse and i were like tilt tonight we're
still friends to this day indeed
because we we've got pictures of each
other in a hotel room with chickens
[Laughter]
and then moving along chapter five
there's this is the one when i read it
i had never heard anything like it ghost
uh ghosts or is that the one
or windows in the past windows in the
past yeah with the little people and the
snakes oh yeah
uh
we got lucky mack and i we
we first of all there there's dry holes
which i know only saw once
and that was this particular mission
where you go in and you don't get any
contact
it's it's like a three-day walk through
through the woods
yeah and uh we got we drew this target
it was on the northwestern edge of of
the of the dm
going up where it climbs up into ocean
plateau
and uh
we went in we were they wanted they just
wanted to find out what was in the area
because that the last after action
report had been from 1967.
somebody had been in that and this is
like in 70 71. yeah yeah so we we draw
the mission and we get up there and
boudreau
had been a 1-0
who he was a launch side nco he had been
a 1-0 when that mission had gotten run
in 67 no is that right yeah but he
wasn't on the team but he remembered
that but he had the area on the ground
and he's giving us a hard time here yeah
you know the last people were in there
you know they came out with their tail
between their legs you know wild stories
and all this
so mac and i get geared up we get get
inserted
and nothing there's we found some tracks
found uh mostly barefoot you know no
sandals no ho chi minh sandals with
truck tires on the bottom no bata boot
these were barefoot
natives so they they had to be yards
so and the yards are all spooky they're
like jittery you know you know
something's going on and you know they
finally get over by
by uh cumin with mac and mac goes uh
like what's going on and
come and go ush number ten
snake people
bad peoples bad peoples
yard no like tahan no like
uh and we're going uh okay so i had to
go back and check the team
and as i wandered to the back and ran
into bond the shaman
and he's the same way he's like looking
around he's a lot more composed than the
rest of them but he's sitting there and
i go uh
bong what are the snake people and he
goes don't say their name
oh
why is that yeah yeah so i'm starting to
think of all these bats i i think
they're headhunters because some of the
brew and some of the sedan had not been
headhunters that long ago
you know back 10 15 years before that
they were still taking heads is that
right oh yeah well yeah okay yeah um
and i think the jurai would like that so
i'm thinking they're headhunters yeah
okay
but the yards are spooked
and we don't see any mba and i asked
bong i said how come no nba here and he
says snake people snake people nba no
come here
nba no come here snake people bad people
you know and you keep hearing it bad
people number ten
and when we we had found this cave
that we were going up we're winding our
way up to this cut notch up to the
plateau
and it was in the one wall of the of the
gorge
and it was probably 20 meters
wide maybe 10 meters deep and at the
back of it was just it was all overgrown
inside with moss and and mildew and [ __ ]
like that there was a bunch of poles
arranged
and there was uh like that
there was the head of a bear a skull of
a bear that was all covered over with
mold
and there was a set of what looked like
aviator
goggles
hanging from a center pole and some
other pieces of equipment and bones that
look like human bones
so and that's really freaked out the
arts oh [ __ ] number two i started to go
in and take a look at it and cooma
grabbed me like i was holding me back
from the edge of a clip
no no no number 10 number 10.
so i pulled back and said well you know
whatever it is let's keep moving so we
move back up the the gorge we get on top
maybe a half a mile from from where we
found the cave and we found the remains
of an old
prop driven fighter aircraft
found an engine
and then
part of the rear
part of it and then the actual fuselage
with the cockpit in it was separate had
separated from one wing
and
i'm up inside of it you know most of our
fighter aircraft
under the pilot seat is a survival kit
that has like a silence 22 and they got
emergency rations and there's a
you know medical kit and
gold
in the form of chains or and why was
that
so i'm looking for that stack i'm
underneath up underneath there and i
don't i find a bunch of crumpled papers
it looked like it was a map and a
journal and that and no gold
but laying on the between the runners
and that is as
a classmate
and it says langley on it well langley
is the official knife maker for the
french army it means bumblebee and that
the little back of the knife on the back
strap is a picture of a bumblebee
so i dug it out of there and i stuck it
in my pocket i still have it to this day
somewhere
you know but uh you know and every time
i feel bad
that i've had bad luck bad women bad
whiskey i blame it on the knife and the
bad luck radee
you know we
we we found this old french aircraft we
figured out we found part of a parachute
and a shoe
a little further from the airplane we
figured the guy bailed out
and the thing
bellied in on the plane of jars up there
and uh they the bad peoples
got him and either killed him or come
across his body and they put the remains
in that cave and that
so we're
we're finally when we find the aircraft
they tell us already get ready to be
extracted and then direct us to an lz
and that when we get to the lz and we
get set up all the way there the yards
are jumpy
you know
you've never seen that before no
neverland
you don't see that kind of hinkiness
yeah the the mountain yards i mean they
could go on the ground and dracula could
be there and they wouldn't give a damn
yeah but whatever it was with smoke
spooking them in that we get to the lz
and we you know get set up and we're
lifting off as we're lifting off i look
back down on the lz and there's two
mountain yards
primitives they're still wearing
loincloths you know one one of them's
armed with a crossbow with the you know
the little
uh quiver and all that the other guy was
carrying a mat 49 french submachine gun
circuit in the 1950s and they had
tattoos
around their eyes and that you know like
like the the sedan sometimes tattooed
themselves like that
and then
when we got back bong the shaman
uh because i had seen him and he had
been with me when i seen him i had to go
for a cleansing where he took me down
into the yard oh yeah took me down to
yard hut and they were burning monkey
balls and hair or something and waving
it around me you know put pennies on my
back you know and
chanting some sort of [ __ ] and that
and mac was could i couldn't go i wanted
to go downtown and no no no we got to
fix your spirit
so that th the bad peoples don't take
your spirit and hold it now you'll have
to stay here and you'll have to drink
this horrible concoction and get smoked
shoved up your ass
meanwhile cookie and them are heading
down to the pink house and i don't want
to go
so they're uh
they're getting ready to leave and they
go you're going to leave me here like
this and they go yeah you know it's your
fault you saw him said really watch this
i turned the bong and i said i saw mack
talking to those to the bad people and
he gave him every mountain yard name
that ended their trip to the pink house
they're sitting with me suffering
through the oh you got to be cleansed
[Music]
now we're really weird target
very very strange i mean uh
obviously they were a mountain yard
tribe
but the
other martin yards didn't trade with
them they didn't intermarry with them
and they were all afraid of and the
north vietnamese were afraid of them too
yeah how many areas and around anywhere
in southeast asia that the nva didn't go
i can only remember one other place over
on the east coast in the dm
where another small splinter group in
that there were the same oh these were
real tall mountain yards wherever they
came from you know probably harlem you
know
but they uh but the only two places i
remember in vietnam totaled that where
there was
we didn't operate in there and the north
vietnamese didn't operate in there for
some reason we didn't operate in there
because there's nobody to go after
right you know and the nba didn't
operate in there i guess because they
sent somebody in there and they
disappeared and they figured well we
just won't go through there again
yeah very very strange target
indeed
and then um i want to go back to your
first book just a little bit here
because um for the indictment
indeed
but the
um get bear with me a second here
because
your first mission
that for you is your first time on the
ground with the team
and
you're
going into the target there's firefights
and in your mind it's just like
um this is a pretty bad target then at
the end of it
they uh oh yeah they explained to you
that this is just this is an easy one
and then the other part two is like i
want to get back a little bit to your
unique relationship with your your
captain
because you're told that
this is a
volunteer operation
and so
you finally after you go through your
briefing and the train you get your
briefing i guess did you get your c your
cnc briefing
after you arrived that denying oh yeah
yeah
the train was basically you went through
there that was headquarters right right
and then you went to whatever project
you'd been sentenced to
and
you when you got there you got briefed
by you know you get you i remember the
day we arrived
you go up to the headquarters up at the
headshed
and they process in all your paperwork
you get to meet the sergeant major for
the project and you know the colonel
gives you a little raw rod talk and then
you get sent to either the hatchet
company or
s4
hickory the combo section or recon right
depending on which one you've been
assigned to
and then
my
first
meeting with captain manus was when i
arrived down in recon company right and
so
this is like
what's it's funny but it also gives you
a little bit of flavor of some of the
characters that you're with there and
captain manus well you got to remember
that manus was a prior nco indeed who
had learned gone to school learned not
to scratch his nuts with the salad fork
and they made him an officer indeed
right so
but he's i mean if you can imagine a
square face bullnecked blonde hair
you know
combat soldier you know and he'd been a
senior nco before and then got a
commission to be a captain
is there a ghost in the house no
no and
so he
you know he he was in charge of recon
company
and it was like uh
jedi related or are you going to well i
i like to get into the book because some
of the language in it was just so funny
as so you're you've arrived at ccn
and they tell you to go down to the
recon company area
and as we walk up to the early room and
getting back to the book we view
dragging our bags with us
our god draws something about
waiting outside in the shade
until the company commander has a chance
to talk with us
he sticks his head in the door and says
something to those inside
he suddenly jerks himself out of the way
just as the door bursts open and a body
flies out
landing in front of us
the man begins to pick himself up
then falls back face first in the sand
he then manages to help himself up and
staggers off towards the back of the
company area
we stare at the retreating form
wondering what this is all about
and then our heads swing up as the door
opens a second time
i'm sorry i is this is another little
insight yeah so a short squat blonde
captain is standing in the doorway with
his fist balled up
without blinking an eye he surveys us
he looks around as if expecting the body
that had preceded him to still be there
he has all the charm of a bouncer at an
orphanage
he sticks out his jaw
apparently in an attempt to punctuate
his next statement
but it fails to delineate
if this troll actually has a neck
he takes a breath and starts in
welcome to recon company i'm captain
manus
but you may call me sir or [ __ ]
sir or just hide when you think i'm
looking for you
i will be assigning you to a team just
as soon as i can because we need warm
bodies
this is a volunteer organization
if at any time you feel that you can't
hack it
all you have to do is come in here and
tell me you're the sergeant major and we
will reassign you somewhere else
gentlemen this is real important
so i hope you have been picking your
ears instead of your ass
if you're too shaky to do this job
you don't need to be
out there
where you can get someone else killed
he pauses which is good because i'm
trying to figure if this is actually a
human being
he gulps a breath
his mouth settles into some sort of
grimace that slashes across the square
features like a
watermark and continues
this is the extent of the briefing
welcoming speech and pre-dark pep talk
are there any questions
if there are there better not be stupid
questions because questions and answers
time cuts into my leisure activities
so at this point you're saying i look at
the sand
and
then he turns to you and you've got a
question
so what was your question well first of
all you got to understand larry the way
you're describing the way this guy in
the book you don't get the full of that
okay when larry talks
you can call me sir you can call me
[ __ ] sir or you can just
[ __ ] hide when i'm looking for you
you know and he's got this no neck
and i'm sitting there i know what the
squat breads all about and i immediately
suspected that he was former nco yeah
yeah i mean there's a you know the
polish is not there
this is not a you know a
military academy project or a product
this is right out of the ranks so i
asked him i said uh
so uh
this is a voluntary outfit
uh
what was wrong with that guy he wanted
to quit
so why why why why did he want to quit
because he's a [ __ ]
and i said but i thought it was a
voluntary outfit he said well
let me what's your name i said brock out
he said well listen broken trout yeah
you're obviously some kind of barracks
room lawyer or you've got you know some
sort of you know hidden agenda in that
i'm gonna put you on rt habu
you know where you can be another burden
to society and maybe between the three
of you you can actually be a real team
so that's how i got assigned uh rt hubba
right down in there
so when i showed up in the hooch oh yeah
jimmy johnson and mac are in there and
they're they're they're cleaning their
guns when i walked in the door shut the
door we don't want the sunlight in here
why dracula in here with you what
and they're cleaning their guns and they
go mac looks at me and goes
let me guess
you've run into captain maintenance
and you had a discussion with him and
then he assigned you to us
i go that's exactly what happened he
said well
you either annoyed him
or he sent you over here to see if you
know he can make
we can make something out of you
and that that's how i ended up and then
castro came in right after that
yeah castillo comes in and fishes a beer
out of the refrigerator and that mac was
sitting there cleaning the silence 22
and shoots the beer can and it starts
peeing all over the place and that and
castro never even breaks breaks stride
he goes well that's that's real good if
you have anything of value make sure
these two don't get their hands on it
because they'll bubblify it
but that was that was my introduction to
habu indeed welcome to the team jimmy
johnson and uh and mclaughlin
well they must have signed you because
he figured that you had you were going
to add some kind of intelligence
and in fact i think maynard said that
that'll make the collective iq in that
hooch
3.
yeah
larry's and i still love the man indeed
well that people don't understand i mean
the officers that we had you know people
read the book and they think that we're
you know we're a bunch of disorganized
disrespectful you know
[Music]
you know out of control troops in that
well we had a lot of respect for our
officers
because they they were victims in our
own little demise and that you know i
mean there were fellow travelers in that
and they were
worse than us
they had some captain come in one time
hey i think he was with the marical
division or something when he got there
he'd read klaus wits and you know
and knew all the arts of war and then by
god he was gonna straighten out recon
company and get us back in uniform make
us act like an army unit and that
unfortunately he did this at the
officers club
and manus uh
see manus i think taylor was there
messenger was there
and i think lightning wonderlick was
there
they decided to save his life
so
they got him drunk
and they took him down to the to the
mountain yard [ __ ] you know that the
the toilets with the 55 gallon drums
they duct taped them
and it stuck him inside
underneath one of the holes
and by by morning he was a babbling
idiot you know they they they had uh
he'd gone completely nuts had a nervous
breakdown and all that
and somebody asked uh manuscript why'd
you do that well we didn't do it
probably one of the ncos did that yeah
right
right
you guys did it to save his life because
we would have committed homicide on him
we didn't suffer fools but at the same
time we had a lot of respect for our
officers the good ones particularly the
good ones yeah and then i i think
the entire time i was there i mean in
recon company
i can't think of one officer that was
was
was a worthless piece of [ __ ]
and every single one of them was a good
combat officer and
probably because of manus
or
see who was there kimmel
remember kimmel yes larry kept that
larry larry who the colonel complained
because he said that we laid around
drunk all the time so that he wanted
recon to run pt
no so the last day that larry is in
command a recon company before he leaves
he leads recon company on the run around
the perimeter road yeah leading recon
company wearing nothing but his boots
and a cigar
recon never ran again that was the end
of that
yo he eventually became a colonel
larry oh yeah he was you know hunter
liggett yeah he was the commander of
hunter liggett
he was also
he told me he was the chief ranger at in
the grand canyon
so i i mean i don't know i mean i call
up his office and everything i said i'd
like to speak to the head ranger
uh
who are you
i'm a friend of his
who do you think is the chief friend
well you know larry kimmel you mean the
grounds manager for the north rim
oh yeah
oh and it turned out it was his boss who
was the head ranger a woman
oh no it was actually yeah and i i got
on the phone with her and there now
larry never answers the phone right 20
minutes after i had that conversation
with that woman he was on the phone
don't ever call my office again don't
ever talk to anybody
do tell
uh good good good people though
beaurey
uh
gary robb oh yeah but
he was the second lieutenant he was
washing the jeep i had stolen the night
right before right yeah yeah
yeah and of course he stayed in and rose
to a two-star gym
i think he was a three-star i think he
got out as a three-star that does it too
trust me
there was another guy who was uh
was an nco and became a a
major general in the marine corps allen
or something like that sam hong he ran
out of ccc oh yeah yeah
and uh
he rose high in the ranks of the marine
corps yeah and he was a general and i
don't remember that yes he was and then
um
well eldon was a staff sergeant
well we were e4s together for b1
in the early days look at look at mo
elmore you know
the half-assed decent staff sergeant and
then he became a colonel
well we'll get back to a little bit of
action here uh regarding your very first
mission
where
um
you just got on the team you did your
training
you get to go order they change things
around max the one zero you're the one
one
and they did a multiple team insertion
or at least they wanted to appear that
way
and then you guys get into the target
and then uh after the insertion
uh you guys are on the ground first
night you set up an ron
right and then you're on the ground for
a while
and uh
i think the next day is when you begin
to make enemy contact
yeah well the other teams got in they
inserted three teams all at once which
is all at once which is a no no i mean
obviously it was fumbai because uh pappy
boudreau would never do that up there
out of quality right that would dover in
that crowd but uh
they put us in we were at the far far
end we were the last team that went in
and the next morning the other team
started getting rolled up
one right after the other
and we got we got hit last
and it was uh
i mean
suddenly we had people all over us
coming from everywhere
and uh
the reason
that the whole thing boils down to this
we were fighting for what i thought was
our lives
that it was desperate
situation and uh you know the yards were
performing perfectly i was doing what i
had to do
and it was the first time that mack and
i had actually been in combat together
so it was a kind of a the bulk and mind
meld between the two of us
and we got done with the thing and uh
max telling me says well that worked out
good
so what do you mean worked out good we
were alive but i didn't think we
accomplished anything he said no there
was a this was training
this is a chance for the mountain yards
to see how well you operated under uh
under stress before we get a tough
target
well i'm looking to think i mean i'm i
was down when we pulled out i think i
had like three magazines left
and i normally carried up a load of
anywhere between
i carried six 30 round magazines and
back then you had 30 rounds we didn't
have those luxuries yeah we got them
because castillo the cat that the cuban
the cuban found a source for that
and we stole that source
away from them and then we ended up with
a truckload of the things that everybody
had enough they were making them you
know the filipino marmers are making
them up and uh making 30 and 40 round
magazines up at the s4 was that right
and they worked pretty good the
even the 40 round the 41 round would jam
yeah i mean i give it i've never used it
for a long push for a spring yeah but in
this particular mission was basically i
thought it was a tough mission
and uh mac just basically said no you
did well the yards like you they think
you're number one
they like the fact you have dialogue
when you're screaming
and you know you're in
it's like getting getting elected to
boys club
but that was that was a tough mission i
thought and
it soon proved that looking back on it
now was a cakewalk by comparison
i mean out after i did my first bright
light
right that that's when i realized that
this [ __ ] could get real serious real
quick so your first bright light was how
many missions into
into your time with mac with uh habu at
that time i think the third or fourth i
said what was the bright light for
specifically uh i went in to get a team
was shot up you know the the 1-0 was
shot up the
1-1 i think it's covered in there as
blue eyes
the where the chopper went down
the one zero was thrown into the river
when the chopper went down the one one
was shot up real bad and we went in to
find out the 1-0 and
and the crew
and when we got there the
the chopper had burned
and one the door gunner all i remember
about him he had really brilliant blue
eyes
and that was the only thing that was
unmarked on him he was completely
charred up burned right down to the
bones
and he oh when i was went to check him
out
he opened his eyes and no more eyelids
he'd you know they would just burp crust
there and he opened his eyes and looked
at me and it freaked me out
and i went to give him a give him a
morphine
right just kill him you know because
there's nothing there to save and then
max stop me says save it we may need the
morphine later
there's there's nothing there he doesn't
even feel pain anymore it's all gone
and that uh sometimes i close my eyes i
can still see that guy
you know
but that was the worst thing about going
in on aircraft was
especially if they burn oh yes it's
horrible
bad bad scene
but that that was the first bright light
with blue eyes i think first yeah pretty
sure that was the first one
yes according to the book yeah that was
that was the one that was west west of
da nang because we launched out of uh
out of off the the psp strip there right
there yeah yeah
so it's one of the lower targets in the
prairie fire yeah i mean it was funny
you know they would
fubio was always getting sucked in
right otherwise and that and then they'd
run things out of da nang because you
could still get out in the ao and
and a lot of times they
fubai was in transition over something
the only salon site that ran
like clockwork
was quantrie
and that was because papi boudreaux was
up there
nobody messed with pappy oh
who's gonna mess with the buffalo yeah
yeah
major slatten was in charge
and the medic and boudreau were giving
him some kind of pharmaceutical cocktail
he didn't even know what century was in
here signed these papers sir
yeah i'm running this place ever sure
you are
but pappy wouldn't let you go in if he
didn't have enough helicopters to get
you out he wouldn't put yet
but bottom line
fubai
they'd put three teams in and only have
enough choppers and air support to get
one up
and that's that's when and most of the
uh the bright lights
the hairy ones we ran we're out of fubai
or one of their one of their boxes and
that yeah
and that after that first mission i
realized after the first bright light
that that first mission really was a
cakewalk by comparison
because bright light will tighten your
ass up yeah and again you'll go in heavy
like you said with the rpd with your car
15 strapped to your back and then the
early days you had your shotgun sawed
off to somebody stole it i would have
taken in a mini nuke if i thought i'd
get away with it
i'm just you know that you're going in
you're going to shoot your way in
grab up all the survivors and shoot your
way back to the helicopters hopefully
intact and get out that's bright light
and it's s
hopefully gathering up all the dead
bodies and then i never i think i did
went on one bright light where
nobody was there there's a lot of dead
people right we picked up a flight crew
that was i mean no they hadn't
booby-trapped the place they hadn't uh
set up an ambush waiting for us to come
back they just killed them and left
but usually there was lots of people
there and they were using any survivors
as bait to try and kill more of you
indeed
yes um i'd like to just go back at the
very beginning of your book you talk a
little bit about
the formation of where this all began
and uh
the uh
what you talked about earlier but the
the writing here
captures some of the history
and the let's like take a few paragraphs
and get into that for a little bit more
reflection after this if you don't mind
yeah
this book is is first of two detailing
the actions and experiences of a small
group of americans and their indigenous
allies who were the backbone of ground
reconnaissance to the republic of
vietnam during the war
the unit that's described here was part
of mac visage
military assistance command
studies and observations group
or just sog
in the eight years that it existed the
small recon companies that were the
center of its activities conducted some
of the most dangerous and daring
missions of the war
originally conceived as a unit capable
of infiltrating the heart of the area
controlled by the north vietnamese in
both laos and vietnam it expanded its
reach to north vietnam cambodia and a
few other places best left unmentioned
during that time companies never
exceeded more than 30 americans
yet they were the best source for the
enemy's disposition and were key to us
military being able to take the war to
the enemy through the air and on the
ground
this was accomplished by utilizing new
and innovative technology
but also heavily relied on the ability
of the individual team members being
able to use tactics as old as those
from the french and indian wars
in that process this small unit racked
up one of the most impressive records of
awards for valor of any unit in the
history united states army
it came at a terrible price however
the number of wounded and killed in
action
resulted in the computation of a life
expectancy
that was measured in a matter of a few
months
those missions today seem suicidal
in 1970 they seemed equally so
yet these men went out day after day
with their indigenous allies consisting
of montana tribesmen vietnamese and
chinese nuns
and faced the challenges with courage
and resolve
after the fall of the republic of
vietnam the indigenous survivors faced
persecution and in some cases wholesale
execution
today the montana minority is still
being persecuted by the central
government
as their traditional life is being
robbed along with the resources of their
homelands in the mountains of vietnam
and laos
in the end
the communist regimes seem determined to
wipe out these amazing people
and that's just a
little bit of a commentary but first it
goes back to
us an aspect of the war
of the little people we left behind
and just how courageous they were
and what
today is is you have some reflections
back on those times with those people
and i know we've had some mountain yard
communities
that are
have been able to flourish in north
carolina pennsylvania and i think
there's one
in in minnesota i'm not sure about that
one
the one in minnesota is also among
not just uh mountain yard but it's mon
hmong also okay and the two guys that
run save the dega people right get all
the kudos in the world those guys have
done a magnificent job over the years
actually
bringing
the survivors
and establishing communities here in the
united states and and
the communities have prospered
uh their children have gone to college
uh
they as diverse they become doctors
lawyers
they own their own furniture companies
one of them's actually a 747 pilot one
of the children
and have a green beret and yeah and uh
and they've they become part of the
fabric of our country and we just they
deserve to be
you know the
yards gave everything
to our effort the yards stayed loyal to
us the yards i i had mountain yards lay
on top of me to keep me from being hit
again
when you go through something like that
that's a bond with the people that you
don't forget like i always tell people
i wear this bracelet because i will be
brew until the day i die
and i am
and most of guys i know we we have an
undying love
for those people and would you know
would do anything for them and they in
turn
remain loyal to us
what was unique about the unitoid was
some of the numbers
in the eight to
nine years that from 1964 to 1973
basically that the unit existed
uh well even when the unit ended it
still existed right it still existed but
they you know something like 8
600 people
served in it as ground combat operations
that's not
the action trash
the s4
the shoe clerks down in the triangle but
the guys who actually ran the missions
and that eight years was something like
around
six or seven thousand and only eighteen
hundred of us survived the war
1800 out of that number survived the war
give you an idea of the casualty i
didn't know anybody i think i knew one
guy
that never got wounded
everybody else had wounded one two three
times most of us would not even write it
up because you'd always getting bomb
trash and shrapnel and stuff and that
you know
unless you're like chaffey and you know
you got nine purple hearts because
you're right up every single time you
got scratched
you know or like carry he's another one
yes yeah
but you know
the
most guys didn't go after most guys
weren't uh metal hunters what we called
them you know there's a few
i know one guy that actually wrote up
his silver star citation before he got
on the helicopter
oh my god but it was i mean it was if
you read the after-action reports from
the mission before that and he did all
those things
and did him again which would have been
qualified for valor and you know a
valorous gallon award and that was
silverstar so he wrote up the silverstar
there's a strange guy though
indeed most of the time like with matt
mack wrote me up
for two bronze stars and a silver star i
never got the silver star
because uh when they closed the project
out it was still pending
and the c-21 that was carrying all the
records back flew into the side of a
mountain down near natrang murphy
actually ran the the bright light on the
plane crash was that right yeah he said
there was paperwork scattered all up in
the trees and that so they just naped
the entire area and scorched it to the
ground in that and mack and cook tried
to submit a later one i said hey give it
up man
i know what i did and it wasn't that
heroic
and if you're trying to get me an award
i suspect you're up to something so i
didn't bother with it but you've got a
lot of guys that have gone back and
you know tried to check their awards
update there's a certain class of those
people now that are trying to
i got a silver star but i'm not happy
with that i should have a medal of honor
yeah and it just cheapens the award you
got a silver star be happy with that you
earned that silver star you're home now
you're home now you know you don't earn
you don't deserve a dlc you don't
deserve a medal of honor be happy with
what you got and the fact that you got
peers that love and respect you up to
this point
yeah
this is the vital part of the
conversation but anyways um i want to
get back mentioned their first book we
few
the second book
whispers in the tall grass and these are
excellent they're well written the story
is about
sog recon
one of our finest teams and
but also
written with a style and panas that is
second to none um tell us a little bit
about what we're going to get in the
near future sir if you got a little
extra time here talk about your third
book
and uh um i just the vagabonds
took my glasses off here
taurus into the heart of darkness
details my time as an exotic dancer in
the philippines
that's when you surrendered your dream
of being a porn star that would be the
one okay
vagabonds was a collective effort
between myself
then a gentleman named jeff miller
jeff miller and i met after vietnam
and we're in the 10th special forces
group together
and then which was a sign where at the
time at fort devins
massachusetts and our swan song was the
uh
was the uh iran hostage raid
you know we both got out at the same
time after the second one collapsed
really oh we were both both of us were
involved in the first one on the
peripheral and then on the second one
i was going in with one of the assault
teams
and miller was was actually on the first
one he handled
moving all those ch-53s around so the
russians wouldn't find out what we were
doing that's how they ended up with the
sea stallions instead of the jolly
greens the jolly greens have the filters
that keep the dust out of the engines
the sea stallions didn't which was a
major failure oh yeah but it was all
done to keep the russians from telling
the iranians
they're coming
you know so
but
when we got out we formed
a friendship that's lasted
50 some years
and we
we were doing things that eventually
developed into the contractor industry
in those days she go found somebody
convinced him that he needed something
and then showed up at his doorstep as
the answer to his problem
and we we did a lot of that
we did kidnap recoveries in the middle
east
in chechnya
in
in mexico
colombia
we did we trained
police forces in the united states under
the international association of chiefs
police
swat seminars
we did training for foreign countries
like taiwan korea
uh
colombia brazil
um a couple other places that's not
unmentioned
to train
special groups you know police and or or
military
um
what else should we do
computers verify well let's just get
people to convert will will your book be
available for a pre-order
yeah it's available now you can it's on
amazon
please tell us so vagabonds is on amazon
now is on amazon you can pre-order all
right
and um any as we get down here at the
end any last closing thoughts anything
you want to add or something we should
cover just
it's your time
give me a moment i'll give you two
moments if you like now i
pleased to be here i'm glad you guys had
me and
there's
so much to talk about
with special projects indeed because
special projects is the backbone of what
we have now the things that we did that
we conceived and then good and that we
nurtured and handed off to the next
generation
is what makes special operations so good
today
because we imbued in them not only the
technical aspects but the fact that
you have to be a bit of a
of a of a bastard child
in order to survive in this business
and that that was the one thing that i
felt very proud of was the fact that
group has always neutered that
up until
recently when when all the carpet
baggers and
when they made
when they made it a branch right that's
what ruined it because now then officer
could come in and stay in
and stay in the branch before you were
an infantry officer artillery officer
chemical officer you came to special
forces you punched your ticket you moved
on and then you came back after you made
feel great
today
they they grow up and
i think in a bubble
but the teams are the same i've talked
to a lot of enlisted men over the years
and that in different places
one thing that holds true
no matter how dark the night
no matter how dangerous the mission
if you show up at an mss
full of special forces
with purloined booze and stakes
you're welcome with open arms
as if you're a relative
and if you have ammo you get extra
points
indeed and and and it's true at the team
level today we've had the honor of
meeting some of these team members at
different groups
in recent months and uh the young men
that wear the funny looking hat that
keeps neither the rain nor the sun out
of your eyes um
are the highest quality perhaps a little
bit better than we were in our day now
they're smarter better educated
no
i promised you i would never tell this
indeed you promised but now we're on
live
i ran into the team sergeant
and the team
when i was selling armored cars
over in iraq
who had found
hussey and usai's
private car collection
and they were selling them through the
kurds
back into germany and like that they
were taking the money and using it to
pay their intel contacts and the reason
they were doing that was because when
they got money from the from the
military
a bunch of mucks up there at mi and that
and over at the post office in langley
when they get money from them they had
to write down who they gave it to what
the address was what was for in that and
they were getting their all their they
weren't getting info anymore because the
the opposition was killing them up
because
they had the phones tapped or they knew
some state department guy or they were
sleeping with some state department guy
and got the information so
that innovativeness was still there
indeed they took that money for the sale
of those cars and they were paying their
their agents in hard cash and take one
dime for themselves and take one dime to
buy one case of booze or anything like
that everything went back into the op
fun and for that i feel extremely proud
to know those guys indeed i promised i
wouldn't tell i can give up your names
john yes we will but not today we'll
come back for a second session on the
names to be given up well nick thanks
for joining us today and again uh the
three books are amazing reading
um just go to nick brockhausen and
amazon.com
and take a look at the book and there's
many stories in there we just scratched
the surface as jocko would say
on this busy day and we thank you for
joining us so at this point i want to
thank jaco
for having us
do podcast number three today
and have an outstanding guest like this
we have more coming up soon
and uh as we close out we want to thank
today's service members our first
responders
every
everybody who's on the front lines
particularly with these times with the
virus and um
anybody in between firefighters
and
if i forget anybody nick
who do you think
well that thought will close and we'll
be back and ships at sea ships at sea
indeed
thank you and until next time god bless
god bless america